nello spirito della gente che riesce
ad uscire di casa per mettersi a
contatto con gli altri
qui non succede ben utile di tutto non
si sente neanche
la signora che avete visto nel filmato
si chiama in una franca
noi l'abbiamo conosciuta e vive vive a
tre se non l'abbiamo conosciuta perché
un giorno
passando davanti alla frutta e verdura
ma sud della strada dove dove abito
ma chiamato ma il sud ma dico guarda c'è
una lettera per te questa lettera questo
è l'originale della lettera è una
calligrafia molto bella una carineria
antica molto chiara
normalmente non riceviamo queste lettere
con richieste di supporti economici in
questo caso qui era completamente
diverso io l'ho letta con molta
attenzione
e qui c'è la storia la signora di 68 81
anni ho vissuto a bologna tanti anni mi
sono poi trasferita anni fa a trieste e
in questa città io non mi trovo più non
so cosa fare ho letto dall'assenza di
social strette su un giornale
l'intervista che ne hanno fatto ho letto
del dl del frutta e verdura che il
nostro fermo posta e gli ho mandato
questa lettera questa faccio questa
richiesta associa stretta aiutatemi a
tornare a bologna non fatemi morire in
una città dove la gente non si saluta
la cosa è strana molto originale questa
cosa qui perché a 300 chilometri di
distanza ea 45 anni anche di distanza
federico bastiani aveva aveva avuto la
stessa problema la stessa intuizione che
pur vivendo in una città come bologna da
diversi anni passando per via fondazza
non conosceva assolutamente nessuno e
noi ce l'abbiamo questa sensazione molto
spesso però ci fermiamo lì mentre
federico
gruppo daydreamer ha detto va bene
proviamo a fare qualcosa
vediamo se utilizzando un mezzo che
normalmente viene utilizzato per mettere
in contatto le persone che vivono
lontano posso conoscere il mio vicino di
casa follia lui l'ha fatto comunque
questo qui è l'originale del primo
volantino che lui
ha creato e attaccato sotto i portici di
bologna sotto gli archi dei portici di
via fondazza
per informare i cittadini residenti in
via fondazza che c'era questo gruppo
questo è un volantino importante perché
dice esattamente qual era lo scopo di
questo gruppo
l'obiettivo è quello di creare un punto
di riferimento per i residenti in questa
strada storica strada c'è ancora
l'errore originale al fine di
socializzare organizzare incontri
esprimere necessità o esigenze una
società e una sorta di bacheca stradale
settembre 2013
ci aspettavamo aspettava io sono stato
uno dei primi che aderito ci aspettavamo
pochissime adesioni 10 20 30 persone che
aderissero è stata una follia totale
perché in poco tempo veramente centinaia
di persone si sono iscritte a questo
gruppo non ce lo aspettavamo
assolutamente
e la domanda abbiamo cominciato a farci
delle domande per che cosa succede
perché queste persone hanno c'è questa
corsa ad aderire a questo gruppo
la domanda la lasciamo la risposta la
lasciamo in sospeso pensa di aver tempo
di parlarne poi dopo quello che è
interessante quello che è successo un
gruppo facebook
appunto è il mondo qui molto virtuale
stiamo nel virtuale cosa c'entra con la
strada del facebook non cibo non entra
niente però facebook è uno strumento
come tanti altri
come il martello che si utilizza per che
voglio per per rompersi un dito quello
che è successo immediatamente e che le
persone ha cominciato a interagire sul
web ea scambiarsi informazioni quindi
tutto quello che succedeva restava sul
web quindi anche le persone non si
conoscevano ha cominciato a conoscersi
in che modo semplicemente chiedendo
informazioni sulla strada una dei punti
forti di questa struttura e residenti in
via fondazza a bologna un posto molto
delimitato quindi le persone a cui
chiede vi dov'è il medico migliore che
rispondevano immediatamente per ogni
domanda tre risposte dove posso chicchis
agli orari
del calzolaio che chi mi può dire dove
il miglior negozio di frutta e verdura e
via dicendo quindi le persone cominciato
a interagire fra di loro un livello
assolutamente virtuale però sulla strada
non se eravamo ancora però
automaticamente le persone cominciano
anche a fidarsi degli astri a dire bene
chi mi può dargli una mano una macchina
ferma in strada che mi può dare una mano
a caricare cioè di accendere a spingerla
molto spesso la gente sia vieni giù che
siamo già qui che ti diamo una mano a
spingere la macchina che mi dà una mano
per esempio nel trasloco che mi che mi
può per esempio tenere il gatto per per
una settimana
un giorno delle richieste ma di
richieste d'aiuto ma anche delle offerte
o un tavolo che non mi serve più chi lo
vuole oppure vado in vacanza o un
frigorifero pieno chi ti serve questo
cibo chi lo vuole
a questo punto alle persone per forza di
cose su dovute incontrare in strada e
questi scambi sono aumentati in questo
anno in maniera esponenziale
certamente c'è da dire che a fronte di
centinaia di persone che interagivano
che si scrivevano e poi interagivano la
percentuale poi di persone che si
conoscevano della metterà molto bassa ma
anche di questo penso che ne parleremo
in seguito
la cosa importante è cosa di certo punto
a parte questa automaticità dei rapporti
di richieste da che venivano dalle
persone abbiamo cominciato a pensare
anche di fare qualcosa
fare qualcosa che potesse attirare le
persone in strada anche a prescindere
dalle singole necessità
quindi a parte gli aperitivi a parte
voglio dire i compleanni e via dicendo
per esempio abbiamo pensato questa è la
prima questa lo facciamo vedere perché
la prima attività che noi abbiamo fatto
organizzata pensavamo flash mob di
natale c'erano due o tre persone in
strada nella strada che sapeva suonare
quindi diciamo proviamo a vedere chi
viene a festeggiare in strada no il
natale con noi bella sorpresa è stata
che
in questa occasione non siamo trovati
con circa 200 persone in strade altri
200 alle finestre
erano due mesi praticamente che era nato
il gruppo quindi abbiamo già avuto la
sensazione che qualcosa funzionava che
le persone avevano bisogno di questa
partecipazione era una richiesta che
facevano di essere anche spinte a uscire
in strada perché ci pare noi non abbiamo
sedi presenta non è un non è un comitato
non è un'associazione non ci sono
tessere assolutamente niente la strada
il nostro luogo di ritrovo e quindi
siamo andati avanti anche con altre
attività un'altra per esempio molto
bella è stata uno shooting fotografico
un ragazzo che abita la strada lavora
come manager alla laica di firenze e si
è offerto di fotografare tutti gli
abitanti della strada verranno 56 150
persone 200 persone si sono presentate
abbiamo fatto questa mossa incredibile
dei volti però c'è da dire in questo i
volti di affondarsi messa sul muro
vedete con le mollette niente di che è
un formato veramente sono fotocopie
veramente la qualità non era così
importante per noi la cosa molto
importante è sempre quella creare delle
attività per fare in modo che le persone
abbiano una scusa per incontrarsi e
andiamo avanti siamo passati anche
letture ad alta voce nei vari cortili
quindi non andiamo in un posto specifico
ma andiamo dei diversi cortili delle
case ap alle letture e di base ha
passato un altro livello l'altro livello
a il livello di dire la strada di solito
ha una storia e le storie
bisogna conoscere perché
storia e appartenenza storia è qualcosa
che ti fa vedere non i muri ma quello
che c'è dietro i muri quello che c'è
stato questo è uno degli esempi che sta
che di via fondazza famosissime poi le
streghe voglio dire come tutte le strade
povere era una categoria femminile ben
definita che per sopravvivere poi faceva
anche i filtri d'amore ma faceva anche
tutt'altro e anche queste storie e
storia della grande fondazza cioè
fondazza è una strada dove viveva anche
il
pittore morandi
non gianni come ha detto qualcuno
possiamo intervistare il morandi o campo
difficile perché è un po morto abbiamo
detto però in questa
sera c'era morandi che era assolutamente
dando morandi era assolutamente una
sociale incredibile assolutamente però è
frequentata anche da dal carducci quindi
tutte persone che hanno in qualche modo
interagito con questi personaggi sono
venuti a parlare ostra e questa non è
gente che sta su facebook queste sono
persone che che che non utilizzano
assolutamente facebook un giorno di san
giovanni per stato un cartello e noi che
non usiamo facebook come facciamo a
partecipare no è molto molto bello credo
che è un altra attività in cui siamo
scesi invece un terzo tipo di attività
in cui ci prendiamo cura del territorio
delle cose che ci sono nel nostro nel
nostro territorio non strazzata questo
caso il proprio il giardino di morandi
ha mandato completamente in rovina e
siamo occupati noi poi di ripulirlo ci
occupiamo delle fioriere ma ogni volta
li costruiamo noi ogni volta il motivo e
per ritrovarsi la domenica mattina a
fare qualcosa insieme socializzare la
cosa più importante il nostro l'altro
punto certamente e prendersi cura di una
strada vuol dire anche trovare dei posti
dove poter socializzare le nostre città
sono poverissime di posti dove
socializzare sul wall sedere deve andare
in un bar si vuol bere dell'acqua deve
andare in un bar e lasciamo perdere
altri servizi assolutamente noi in pochi
mesi si è riusciti a pedonalizzare
questa piazzetta che assolutamente al
centro della nostra strada con una
chiesa bellissima e con una storia
bellissima delle scuole che suore
canterine di aver santa cristina che è
che è un posto meraviglioso
assolutamente doveva fatto dei concerti
anche dove certi fatte anche d'azzardo
c'è stata data proprio per la valenza
sociale
allora questo l'ho messo semplicemente
non per chissà che cosa ma in effetti
noi ci sentiamo un laboratorio di strada
quello che sta succedendo infondata è
qualcosa di incredibile perché
nessuno se l'aspettava innanzitutto nei
proprio assolutamente nessuno noi
abbiamo attualmente circa
fra i 25 30 tesi di laurea di sociologia
di antropologia di
psicologia anche lo yen la sapienza via
dicendo questo veramente
colpisce molto è tutto questo perché
perché attualmente in via fondazza nel
gruppo residente in via fondazza siamo
circa mille persone
ma dopo vedremo che la cosa sia
assolutamente espansa c'è da considerare
la mente tantissime cose perché le
persone che non si conoscono neanche
cominciano a parte voler partecipare a
un progetto di socialità cos'è successo
l'ala ultraottantenne
signora che chiede alla sua dirimpettaia
ultranovantenne che chiede la sua
dirimpettaia ma disse ma cos'è la stessa
società stretta e quello glielo spiega
le dice ma allora cos'è quello che
facevamo noi la bozza 50 anni fa
beh sì si faceva 50 anni fa ma adesso
non si faceva più non si fa più cioè di
interagire con le persone di salutarsi
di scambiarsi il saluto di conoscersi si
vive nelle strade senza avere nessuna
concezione di chi sta vicino allora
questo modo qui che questo è lo scopo la
socializzazione molto spesso è il
semplice basta saluta le persone per
strada
io lo vedo io ci mettevo cinque minuti a
fare via fondazza l'anno scorso
quest'anno ci metto due ore e mezza
quindi quando prende il treno laddove
van fra parte perché sono ci arrivo in
stazione questo per dire che conosco le
facce con lo spi nome delle persone
conoscono le storie delle persone e
questo è assolutamente importante perché
ci arricchisce notevolmente oggi abbiamo
sentito le cose meravigliose no nella
medicina nel anche per esempio vivere un
ambiente altamente sociale dove ti senti
bene fa diminuire del 20 per cento se
non sbaglio uno studio recentemente
pubblicato le malattie cardiovascolari
per esempio da un punto di vista
economico a vivere in un ambiente dove
c'è questo scambio che non è il fine di
social street non è assolutamente quello
il fine però si risparmio calcolato
intorno ogni famiglia intorno ai 2.000
euro quindi è importante anche io questo
punto di vista ci vien da chiedere
perché è più facile che c'è una delle
persone che chiedono di quelli che danno
ai certamente questo è un punto
importante è più lento di vista
psicologico perché per noi ormai non
siamo neanche più abituati a chiedere
l'aiuto degli altri
noi abbiamo un rapporto di 1 a 3 1 a 4
penso che sia molto importante rivedere
anche questo punto da davanti
velocemente abbiamo fatto il primo
compleanno quest'anno con i mille con
con i mille iscritti ma i numeri non
contano contano contano veramente dei
contano veramente le interazioni fra
persone non facciamo mai assemblee e in
ordine
non ci servono sono piccoli gruppi che
si auto organizzano per cui trekking
urbano le cene e queste cose che sono
tutti i piccoli gruppi di persone che
possono parlare fra di loro e conoscersi
vado molto velocemente avanti per perché
voglio tornare a dirvi innanzitutto in
italia ormai sono centinaia le social
site presenti decine stanno facendo di
tutto il mondo su questo modello di via
fondazza e noi siamo molto orgogliosi
perché fondasse il primo modello al
mondo di social street siamo anche in
america latina e nuova zelanda in
croazia via dicendo voglio per gli
ultimi gli ultimissimi secondi voglio
soltanto dire di tornare alla signora
franca la signora franca noi avevamo
pubblicato la sua storia sulla nostra
pagina e immediatamente in due giorni
non abbiamo trovato chi si occupava di
del trasloco gratis da trieste a bologna
abbiamo trovato la casa bologna l'ho
chiamata e l'ho detto signora franca è
tutto a posto agli anni fa signor luigi
ivaldi veramente a questo punto qui io
ho paura di tornare a bologna è mio è
uno sfogo mi sentivo veramente sola
adesso so che ci siete
quindi per il momento voglio restare qui
questa è un'altra bella lezione perché
alla fine molto spesso non abbiamo
bisogno non abbiamo bisogno di grandi
aiuti ma di sapere che nel caso in cui
avremo bisogno qualcuno c'è